we went an extended period of time
shireen between
occasions where we heard from cowboys
owner jerry jones it was the draft
and then a week or two into training
camp and
it sparked a lot of concern speculation
discussion
where is jerry during all of these
important issues that came up over the
course of the summer well
he's now back onto his twice per week
schedule of calling in to 105.3 the fan
in dallas that's something that has
generated headlines
and posts that we could write at
profotballtalk.com for years now
he's scheduled to be back on again today
and it's far different circumstances
than when he was on
tuesday and on tuesday he made it clear
that he's going to try to reach some
sort of a compromise when it comes to
the national anthem
some sort of a of a protest or
demonstration before
maybe take a knee before stand during
and chris and i spent a lot of time on
wednesday saying that just doesn't mess
with the messages coming from the
commissioner that there should be full
and complete support of the players who
choose
to protest during the anthem now stephen
jones the ceo of the cowboys makes
regular appearances on 105.3
the fan in dallas he was on yesterday
shireen and he he was
asked whether he agrees with roger
goodell's blanket thoughts on
support for players who kneel and
remorse toward
colin kaepernick here's what stephen
jones had to say in response to that
this week the commissioner said the nfl
was wrong for not listening to colin
kaepernick and other players
earlier do you guys agree with that i'm
not going to comment on that
at this point i mean obviously everybody
i have respect for what everybody has to
say
about any of these situations everybody
has their own way of
of getting their hands around it it's
obviously a
big challenge and as i said every
organization
every office every place looks at a
little different including
whether you're the nfl or you're an
individual club everybody has their
their views on uh on different things so
uh certainly have respect for
everybody's uh
opinions and and views but uh
probably as far as i'd go with that
hey sharing this is one of those
examples where if the answer is anything
other than
yes the answer is no
and stephen jones said enough to make it
clear that they don't agree with the
commissioner on this
and this this idea that the individual
clubs
are separate apart from the league this
just gets back to the point we were
making the other day
if the commissioner cannot or will not
make that phone call to stephen and or
jerry and say this is the way we
do things here guys then they may as
well
scrape roger goodell's name off of the
football and put jerry jones signature
on it instead
because he's the guy who's in charge not
roger goodell
well that's exactly right mike and let's
back up to
when colin kaepernick first started
sitting for the anthem and then it
turned into a neil after he talked
to some veterans that was august 26th of
2016
and then it boiled over into the nfl
where after president trump said some
things then
everyone in the nfl was kneeling the
cowboys are one of the lone teams not to
have a player
ever protest during the night during the
playing of the national anthem
afterwards yes but not during the
playing of the national anthem
jerry jones has been able to work out
some great compromises
back then when every team started doing
it the whole entire team he went out and
joined them they took a knee against
arizona in a
nationally televised night game
everybody what are the cowboys going to
do they all took a knee and then they
stepped back on the line toes on the
line
as jerry likes to say say and for the
playing of the national anthem
then let's fast forward last year they
pick up robert quinn and michael bennett
who have protested during the anthem
repeatedly at other teams what happens
they don't protest
when they get to dallas there were
contractual things that were made done
that those guys decided to stand for the
anthem now
michael bennett walked behind the bench
drinking a cup of water but he did stand
for the national anthem
while in the one year that he was with
the cowboys jerry jones has always been
able to work out compromises
i just don't see a compromise in this
situation and talking to players i don't
think there will be a compromise
the one thing he has working for him is
dak prescott and ezekiel elliott have
always
followed jerry and they have agreed to
stand on that line and they are the team
leaders
but don terry poe has already said i am
kneeling for the national anthem i don't
care what the rest of my teammates do
so it's going to be interesting to see
what kind of
compromise jerry thinks he's going to
get out of this
yeah and this is the guy who likes to
throw his arm around a player and get a
player to see things his way
it was a big story last year when it
comes to contracts because ezekiel
elliott
held the cowboys at arm's length as long
as he could and held out for
the best deal he could get and it's
still an issue as it relates to dak
prescott because i think we all thought
there was a chance
when they got closer and closer to july
15 jerry jones was going to have that
heart to heart directly with dak
to get dak to see it his way and agree
to whatever their best offer was and i
think he believes he can do that
with anyone that he can essentially
sweet talk anyone into seeing it his way
and realizing that his way should be
their way
and my concern is
in this climate especially given
everything that's happened since the
last time he spoke on 105 3 the fan in
dallas
what happened wednesday what happened
thursday
i just think the mere act of trying to
fashion a compromise is inappropriate at
this point
i think any effort to try to convince a
player
that what he believes he needs to do in
that moment
is something he shouldn't do is
inappropriate
and that's why i think the league office
needs to step in and it'll be
interesting to see what jerry says today
about it he said tuesday he plans to
talk to don terry po
has he talked to don terry po is don
terry pogan to change his mind
and if he doesn't change his mind train
look i know they're counting on don
terry po
this year but would you put it past the
cowboys to cut don terry poe if they
think
he's not going to stand for the anthem
probably not but mike maybe that's the
compromise
maybe he wants right we won't fire you
yeah right maybe he wants roger goodell
to say this is what you're going to do
that's his out then he can go back to
president trump who we know he's
friendly with jerry has said on repeated
occasions they talk weekly
so he can go back to trump and say hey
man i i tried
i wanted my players to stand for the
national anthem you know how i feel
but this was a league mandate you know
roger goodell called me and told me i
had to do that maybe that's his out
maybe that's what he wants is roger
goodell to tell him what to do in this
case
and then he'll have to do it right
follow league policy maybe that's the
compromise is he blames it on roger
goodell
he's been blamed for everything else
anyway but but here's the thing
it gets back to how the week began
the two-part conversation with emmanuel
acho
uncomfortable conversations with a black
man a popular digital series
the nfl after part one sent out
the the email internally suggesting that
all employees watch part two and here's
the link to part one and they retweeted
both parts of it and and they they kind
of took a victory lap
over this conversation that roger
goodell had with the manual art show
and then came the postscript from jim
trotter who works for the nfl and was on
nfl network saying
i'm not quite sure how uncomfortable
this conversation really was
there are more questions that need to be
answered and one of the things jim
trotter brought up
the connection between goodell and his
father
his father who stood up to the president
when it came to the vietnam
war all those years ago is the
commissioner willing to stand
up to this president and if jerry
moves the pieces on the chess board to
put the commissioner in that spot
will he do it and right now the next
move on that chess board
is the commissioner saying to the
cowboys and i asked the league about
this two days ago
no comment right and just because they
say no comment doesn't mean they're not
doing anything
what's happening behind the scenes to
get jerry
to stand down and if and if jerry goes
on 105 through the fan today sharing
and says well you know since the last
time i was on i had a conversation with
roger goodell and
i've decided that i'm going to let my
players do whatever they want to do
wow now i would not bet anything of
value on that happening
but that would be a sign that we are
moving toward
that being the compromise where jerry
can then say to anyone who would
criticize him whether it's his fans
who may be booing loudly however many he
can cram into the stadium consistent
with texas law when players are kneeling
whether it's the president or somewhere
in between he can say
this was taken out of my hands i don't
know that he voluntarily is going to let
anything be taken out of his hands
but it puts the onus on the commissioner
to at least try
because this is a glaring disconnect
between
the nfl and its flagship team
and it's getting more pronounced as time
goes by
and i think the end result of today's
conversation it's going to be even more
pronounced
yeah and we've already seen cowboys
players publicly
come out and and talk about jerry and
saying he needs to speak up he needs to
talk about these issues which he hasn't
done and
that was gerald mccoy who's now no
longer a cowboy and on terry poe
both are new players from from kerasine
from carolina
but what hasn't happened and i know it
has happened a little bit internally
they have talked about these things and
i know there is some concern within
the team about jerry's stance right now
but what we haven't had happen is that
prescott and ezekiel elliott who are the
team leaders
stand up and say this is what needs to
happen you know and and stand up to
jerry and
and they need to do that too within
their team if this is how they feel
maybe they don't feel that way but if
this is how they feel and they want to
kneel
they're going to have to go to jerry
jones and say this is going to happen
and here's why
there's a key factor in all of this too
we haven't mentioned he had some great
comments yesterday before the cowboys
decided to go ahead with practice and
that's the new head coach
mike mccarthy right at some point
at some point does mike mccarthy
say tactfully and polite politely at
least as tactfully politely as someone
from western pennsylvania
can say and i grew up close to western
pennsylvania and i have some of that
lack of tact and diplomacy
does he say hey this is my team
you hired me to coach this team this is
my locker room this is my team
i know what's going to get my guys ready
to win football games and if you want to
win football games you need to back off
and you need to let me deal with them
and you need to let them
decide how they're going to deal with
the national anthem because what you're
doing is counterproductive
it's not going to help me do what you've
hired me to do now
look i don't know that that conversation
happens either
but there is a guy who's in position to
basically say to jerry and or stephen
back off now he signed onto the job
knowing that
they're not inclined to back off but
maybe this is an issue and maybe this is
the first test of mike mccarthy as coach
of the cowboys
to protect his players from jerry jones
to insulate them from jerry jones
and to say to jerry jones this is my
team not your team at least
once we go out onto the field to play a
game
yeah and they are still in the honeymoon
period for sure because they haven't had
that first
loss so mike mccarthy does still have
jerry's ear and if this is an issue that
becomes important within the locker room
that some guys do want to kneel it might
have to be mike mccarthy who goes to
jerry and
and says this is going to happen or
you're going to lose this football team
and this
is what we need to have have done and at
that point it does change so
i'm going to be very curious on what the
quote unquote compromise or what jerry
comes up with or how this plays out
because there's a lot of ways this thing
could go right now they could completely
lose this locker room and
a really good team could have a really
bad season on this one issue i i do
think their season hinges on
on what happens over these next couple
of weeks and sharing it shouldn't fall
on mike mccarthy
it shouldn't fall on any of the players
and
and and i don't want to harp on this
excessively but
to the extent that the league believes
that the roger goodell interview with
emmanuel art show
was in some way something that we should
look to and say
that's an impressive conversation the
words
are meaningless unless the commissioner
tells the cowboys to knock it off and
someone said to me boy it's like you're
challenging the commissioner
i am the challenge to you roger goodell
is to make the words you uttered to
emmanuel acho
meaningful and tell your flagship
franchise
to stop it now
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports